lors de cette troisième journée de
championnat de nationale 2 les féminines
de montigny était en courant alternatif
faso sambre avesnois handball les jeux
saint-quentinoise sont passés à côté de
leur première période multipliant les
pertes de balle
de retour des vestiaires la bande du
gabriel pargoire auteur d'une belle
performance personnelle avec neuf
réalisations reprend le chemin des
filets mais n'a pu réduire l'écart de
sept buts creusé à la pause face aux
sambre avesnois handball équipe qui joue
la montée
je vous ai mis notait n'ont une nouvelle
fois souffert physiquement dans les
duels
score final 32 25 la smh n'a plus que
deux points d'avancé sur les relégables
et les matches à gagner impérativement
arrive dans quelques semaines déçus
d'autres périodes j'avais dit aux filles
à la mi temps qu'il fallait absolument
qu'on gagne la deuxième commande une
meilleure image ils ont fait vraiment
très très bon match en deuxième mi temps
voilà l'écart était fait à pain aux noix
vise la montée ou le maintien on n'est
pas dans la même catégorie
on a fait un bon match dans l'ensemble
je regrette un peu la paix remis dans
vous n'avez pas la pression la pression
là juste par rapport à faire un bon
match pour faire un bon match pour
essayer de progresser
maintenant on joue des équipes parce
qu'ils sont de haut de tableau
on espère qu'au mois de novembre les
matchs qui seront à notre portée on doit
les gagner cela soit important